[music]
Dear attendees, I ask you now
to honor the memory of
Ukrainian heroes of different times with a moment of silence who
fought for the freedom and independence of
Ukraine and gave their lives for it.
We will give Ukraine such strength that it is enough
to always win and we will be harsh
with all those who try
break from the middle
sell out
weaken Ukrainian power
[music]
what the Ukrainian people have been through
we see what is threatening
we are fighting against the enemy and we know that we
know how to win and we will win
Ukrainian children have disappeared in Ukrainian
squares and streets the same way they will celebrate
Ukrainian independence
our grandchildren will celebrate their grandchildren  in the same way
together with the friends of our state with the
allies and partners of Ukraine whom
Ukraine will always freely choose